BELONGINGS IN HER ROOM.
OUR KATE BENNETT IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: AS DONALD TRUMP
RAINS AGAINST THE FBI'S SEARCH
OF MAR-A-LAGO EARLIER THIS
MONTH, HIS WIFE, MELANIA TRUMP,
IS DOING WHAT SHE OFTEN DOES,
STAYING QUIET.
THOSE WHO SPOKE TO CNN SAY
PRIVATELY MELANIA TRUMP WAS
"ANNOYED" BY FEDERAL AGENTS
SEARCHING HER HOME.
HER THINGS DISPLACED, HER
CLOSETS UP ENDED.
HER HUSBAND POSTING, JUST
LEARNED AGENTS WEN THROUGH THE
FIRST LADY'S CLOSETS.
SURPRISINGLY, LEFT THE AREA IN A
RELATIVE MESS.
THE EVER-PRIVATE FORMER FIRST
LADY LIVES FULL TIME AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
SHE'S RETREATED OUT OF THE
PUBLIC EYE SINCE LEAVING
WASHINGTON.
ONE OF THE LAST SIGHTINGS WAS
LAST MONTH PARTING THE FUNERAL
SERVICE FOR IVANA TRUMP.
ON JANUARY 6th, 2021, SHE SAID,
I WAS FULFILLING ONE OF MY
DUTIES AS FIRST LADY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND ACCORDINGLY, I WAS UNAWARE
WHAT WAS SIMULTANEOUSLY
TRANSPIRING AT THE U.S. CAPITOL
BUILDING.
HER ONLY MEDIA POST WHITE HOUSE
THIS MAY, BEFORE THE FBI SEARCH.
>> TIME FLIES FAST, AND WE ARE
JUST -- EVERYBODY IS DOING VERY
WELL.
>> Reporter: THOSE WHO KNOW HER
TELL CNN THERE WOULD BE NOTHING
OF DONALD TRUMP'S IN MELANIA
TRUMP'S LIVING QUARTERS.
NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE SEPARATE
BEDROOMS, ONE PERSON SAYS SHE
WOULD NEVER ALLOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TO STORE HIS ITEMS IN
HER SPACE.
HER INTEREST OF LATE, MELANIA
TRUMP HAS APPARENTLY BECOME AN
ENTREPRENEUR IN THE NFT
CRYPTOCURRENCY RETAIL BUSINESS,
PROMOTING A LITTLE KNOWN
WEBSITE, SELLING DIGITAL
CHEKTIBLES, AND MOMENTS FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, FEATURING
HER PICTURE.
IT'S THE HOCKING OF MEMORABILIA
FOR PROFIT BY A FORMER FIRST
LADY.
THERE IS NO CHARITABLE COMPONENT
TO THE WEBSITE, RAISING
EYEBROWS.
>> I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON MY NFT
PROJECTS SINCE I LEFT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
MY NFTs, THEY ARE AVAILABLE ON
MELANIATRUMP.COM.
>> Reporter: ONE FORMER ADVISER
GOING SO FAR AS TO SAY, IT'S
WEIRD.
IT IS UNUSUAL FOR A FORMER FIRST
LADY TO SPEND HER TIME ON A
NARROW NICHE.
CNN HAS REACHED OUT SEVERAL
TIMES FOR CLARITY ON WHETHER
FUNDS HAVE GONE TO ANY SPECIFIC
CHILDREN'S CHARITIES, AND HAS
NEVER RECEIVED A RESPONSE.
>> PEOPLE I SEE ALWAYS CRITICIZE
ME WHATEVER I DO.
I'M USED TO THAT.
I MOVE FORWARD.
>> SO KATE, THIS NFT VENTURE,
LOOKS LIKE, AS YOU REPORTrd, A
FOR-PROFIT BUSINESS, DO WE KNOW
THE MOTIVE FOR STARTING IT?
>> Reporter: I SPOKE TO SEVERAL
PEOPLE WHO TALK TO MELANIA
TRUMP.
THEY SAY THERE IS CONCERN AND
WORRY NOT KNOWING WHAT THE LEGAL
ISSUE ALSO BRING WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
BUT FORMER FIRST LADIES ONLY GET
A $20,000 A YEAR PENSION AFTER
THEIR HUSBANDS DIE.
IT'S SORT OF A PALTRY SUM WH